ein unscheinbarer pavia im innenhof des
kinderspitals zürich er stammt von einem
künstler der uns immer wieder staunen
lässt der amerikaner james turrell
er macht das lichtkunst und für das
kinderspital hat da diesen raum
erschaffen my light mein licht
[Musik]
er malt mit licht farben bildet einen
raum zu schauen auch nach innen
spendet trost und schärft unsere
wahrnehmung james turrell ist ein magier
des lichts
[Musik]
es fühlt sich an als tauche man in einem
traum in ein universum aus licht und
farben das betört aber auch verstört
ganzfeld nennt man räume die einem das
gefühl geben die orientierung zu
verlieren wie der apa
ein raum den james turrell schon einmal
2011 an der biennale in venedig
inszenierte licht ist immer da
wir tragen es mit uns die eigenschaften
des lichts entwickeln eine eigene
realität
mich interessiert stets wie wir nicht im
traum sie diesem licht will ich in
meinen arbeiten möglichst nahe kommen
nicht denjenigen dass ihr mit offenen
augen sehen
das museum frieder burda in baden-baden
zeigt er als ausstellung des ostens of
light noch bis ende oktober
der us-amerikaner hat räume und
werkgruppen geschaffen die uns
auffordern genau hinzuschauen
der alltag bleibt draußen das spiel mit
licht und farben ist anspruchsvoll
verhören und augen
[Musik]
wir sind für das zwielicht gemacht für
die höhle wenn man das licht reduziert
und sich die pupillen öffnen dann hat
man den eindruck mit dem auge das licht
die farben fühlen zu können
dieses gefühl es bei schwachem licht
viel stärker als bei helligkeit
1943 wird er als kind einer quecker
familie geboren
früher ist er fasziniert von licht
später studierte er mathematik und
wahrnehmungspsychologie wird flieger als
pilot begeistert in der ganz feld effekt
der entsteht wenn man durch wolken
fliegt und scheinbar die orientierung
verliert er beginnt mit
himmelserscheinungen licht räumen und
deren wirkung zu experimentieren
seit mehr als 40 jahren arbeitet er an
seinem wahn witzigsten projekt dem roden
crater einem erloschenen vulkan in der
wüste von arizona
ich wollte vor dem hintergrund
geologische prozesse einen raum über der
erde schaffen in dem vorgänger am himmel
in licht umgewandelt werden
es ist das werk seines lebens ein
unterirdisches museum hier wollten wir
ihn treffen
doch der 75 jährige künstler erlitt vor
wenigen wochen einen herzinfarkt muss
sich nun schonen und hat alle interviews
abgesagt
[Musik]
dafür treffen wir ihm gerd buller der
zürcher architekt plante zwischen 1990
und 1999 den roden crater was reizte ihn
daran den verrückten lebens traumtores
umzusetzen die idee ich verrückt
genommen erfolgt sie vision wo james
turrell beschrieben hat ist absolut
faszinierend gesehen und der vaac das
stattfindet ist ein außergewöhnlicher
werk von architekt gerd buller von james
turrell endlich den architekten der es
verstand seine ideen zu verwirklichen
[Musik]
gerd buller bereitet zurzeit gemeinsam
mit sabine streuli eine ausstellung an
der eth zürich vor das institut für
theorie und geschichte der architektur
wird 2019 die planung des roden crater
zeigen
das ist ja egal intercard der schüssel
denn der 300 meter lang ist tanja
alphakanal genannt wird und dass ein
stück sahne mond sonne und mut
alle himmelserscheinungen sind im roden
crater auf sie ausgerichtet mit seinen
tunneln seinen stufen zum himmel seinen
sky spaces schärft turrell unser sehen
unser hören
unsere konzentration dieses spaces mit
ihrer decken öffnung umrahmen den himmel
als wäre er ein bild wie plant man
solche räume die das licht des sonnenauf
oder untergang einfangen man muss sich
entscheiden welches ohne luft genau will
man natürlich am nächst sondern de
ereignis tagen nach gleichheit ereignis
weiters sind ereignis wo in der antike
show dazu geführt haben dass eine
eigentliche sache baut und dann ist der
astronom und da hat das alles
gleichzeitig genau die ist die
strahlungs winkel der sonne stand der
sonne verlauf der winkel trachtet wo das
licht nach anna will unternehmen tun
lockt eine festlege in der neigung und
in der abwägung und man denn die
planiger so ausgerichtet dass man die
spezifische tag erreichen
der astronom die ingenieure architekten
das material turell schweigt zu den
kosten
doch experten schätzen diese bis heute
auf einen mittleren zweistelligen
millionenbetrag
dabei ist nicht einmal die hälfte des
museums fertig ich möchte es natürlich
vor meinem tod abschließen die pläne
sind da es könnte auch von jemand
anderem fertiggestellt werden aber ich
will es selbst noch sehen licht sei wie
ein nahrungsmittel sagt wir brauchen es
um zu leben
es weitet räume james turell öffnet
unseren blick mit seiner lichtkunst
wenn wir uns darauf einlassen kann das
beglücken
auf jeden fall schärft es unsere sinne
und extra jetzt mit dem michael kratzer
mit ein neuer ärztlicher direktor der
kinder später